I study proteins and I'm studying this
group of proteins called fold switching
proteins so they can actually change
their structures and their functions in
response to changes in the cell so you
can kind of Imagine fold switching
proteins are like a Transformer where in
one case the protein is like a robot
that does one thing and then in another
case in response to changes in our
bodies it becomes a car and can do
something else and an advantage to this
is it can respond really quickly to
changes in our bodies if by the end of
my life even one successful treatment
was made based on this that would be
amazing